on the political front president Trump
Friday made a new claim that his former
fixer Michael Cohen had asked him for a
pardon request he says he refused Cohen
testified to Congress under oath last
week denying that he has ever asked mr.
Trump for pardon this comes amidst
another staff shake-up at the White
House with deputy chief of staff for
communications bill shine
resigning shine is the fifth
communications director to lead the
administration president is spending the
weekend at his Florida resort mar-a-lago
that's where we will find errol barnett
who's traveling with the president good
morning Errol
hey there good morning look it remains
unclear why bill Shine is leaving now
just as president Trump faces new PR
challenges the president is voicing
opinions of his former campaign chairman
Paul mana forts jail sentence and is
publicly debating his former fixer
Michael Cohen online Michael Kohn lied
about the pardon I was a stone cold lie
and he's lied about a lot of things on
his way to visit tornado stricken
Alabama
president Trump lashed out against
Michael Cohen for claiming under oath
that he never sought a pardon he knew
all about pardons his lawyer said that
they went to my lawyers and as for
pardon I could go a step above that but
I won't go do it now aboard Air Force
One the president elaborated writing in
a tweet Cohan quote directly asked me
for a pardon I said no Cohan responded
calling the claim just another set of
lies and the president hit back
seemingly quoting a fellow Republican
the only time that Michael Cohen told
the truth is when he pled that he is
guilty have never asked for nor would I
accept a pardon from President Trump
Cohen's lawyer Lanny Davis has
acknowledged Cohen directed his then
attorney to explore possibilities of a
pardon at one point with Trump lawyer
Rudy Giuliani as well as other lawyers
advising President Trump I feel very
badly
I think it's been a very very tough time
for him mr. Trump also weighed in on a
potential pardon for his former campaign
chairman Paul Manafort who was sentenced
to 47 months in prison
Thursday significantly less time than
the recommended sentence for his crimes
of at least 19 years behind bars all of
this comes as White House communications
chief bill Cheyne resigned Friday his
role appearing to diminish in recent
weeks the president intended for the
former Fox News executive to shape more
favorable coverage of the administration
now shine isn't going too far he is now
heading over to the president's
reelection campaign where he will be a
senior advisor Paul Manafort could face
an additional ten years in jail as part
of a separate case in DC this upcoming
week and Michael Cohen begins his
three-year prison sentence in May
Anthony Merrill Barnett thanks Errol